[Musique]
merci d'être fidèle à atv 78 bienvenu
pour un nouveau 7,8 ce politique voici
lé titre fin de trimestre pour philippe
benassaya élu après la démission de
nadia est dans la 11e circonscription le
nouveau député fait le bilan de ses
trois premiers mois dans l'hémicycle
rencontre au palais bourbon
lui aussi est yvelinois mais il siège au
sénat en tant que président gérard
larcher nous a reçu dans sa permanence
de rambouillet nous avons évoqué avec
lui la loi de sécurité globale et son
article 24 mais aussi de la crise
économique et les prochaines régionales
de 2021 et puis le modem des yvelines un
nouveau président jean baptiste à
monique récemment élu maire de ville
peut il était jusqu'à présent le porte
parole aussi du mouvement nous verrons
ses priorités pour ce nouveau mandat
avant de retrouver jean baptiste à
monique le nouveau président du modem
nous partons pour l'assemblée nationale
comment le nouveau député des yvelines
philippe benassaya s'acclimate à ses
nouvelles fonctions et lui qui a dû
quitter son poste de maire de bois
d'arcy en raison de la loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats et nicolas landry
est allé à sa rencontre
il a effectué ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale en octobre dernier
philippe benassaya nouveau député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines a pris
le rythme de l'activité parlementaire
une journée type c'est à la fois des
rencontres des rendez vous du travail
beaucoup beaucoup d'études travail de
commission sur toutes les télés les
thématiques sur lesquelles je suis
engagé donc ce sont des journées
chargées en général le mardi le mercredi
et le jeudi
premier point au programme de sa matinée
une question orale une séance
particulière dans l'hémicycle avec une
question individuelle et directe du
parlementaire aux membres du
gouvernement le député yvelinois va
solliciter la ministre déléguée au
logement auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique
madame la ministre tire votre attention
sur les difficultés que rencontre le
personnel pénitentiaire pour se loger
notamment dans le logement social
plus généralement les modalités
d'application de la loi sru cause de
grosses difficultés aux communes ce
sujet philippe benassaya le connaît à
travers la maison d'arrêt présente à
bois d'arcy ancien maire de cette
commune cette fonction d'élu local lui
permet d'agir aussi dans sa nouvelle
activité de législateurs une expérience
remarquer par ses collègues du groupe
l'est républicain
on a l'impression de philippe b
d'intérieur est toujours été à
l'assemblée nationale tellement il
connaît ses sujets il maîtrise ses
dossiers et surtout c'est un homme de
terrain un racine est ancrée qui défend
des valeurs d'autorité mais aussi de
solidarité
on sent qu'il a une expérience d'élu
local comme j'ai pu l'être moi même et
le fait d'avoir été maire de bois d'arcy
évidemment une familiarité avec beaucoup
de sujets après la réunion du groupe
parlementaire les lui vinoy rejoint son
bureau
membre de la commission des finances
engagé sur les sujets de sécurité
philippe benassaya a déjà travaillé sur
plusieurs textes de loi notamment à
travers des amendements
j'ai fait un amendement sur la police
sur l'essai et sud et centre de
supervision urbain je prends un exemple
dans ma circonscription pour être
toujours très concret le mini de
saint-denis et dans une petite
communauté de communes ça permettrait au
mesnil deux familles de pouvoir se
rattacher à la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin pour
bénéficier des cesu le lien avec sa
circonscription le député des
républicains le conserve avec son rôle
d'élu départemental face à la loi du non
cumul des mandats il a été contrainte de
démissionner de sa fonction de maire
ça c'était un vrai crève coeur très
honnêtement j'ai mis un peu de temps à
passer du rôle de mère à députés donc la
transition n'a pas été évidente puis
maintenant ça va puisque je garde
toujours bien sûr un oeil sur sur sur
bois d'arcy et sur l'ensemble des villes
de la circonscription pour conserver son
ancrage local philippe benassaya sera
candidat pour un nouveau mandat de
conseiller départemental pour le scrutin
de juin 2021
bruno au millième vient donc de passer
la main le président du modem avait donc
aujourd'hui remplacé par jean-baptiste à
monique voici quelques semaines les
militants ont désigné à la tête de la
formation dans le département bonjour
jean baptiste à monique bonjour wilfried
et merci d'être en ligne avec nous vous
êtes aussi depuis cette année le nouveau
maire de villepreux de multiples
responsabilités avant d'évoquer votre
formation déjà peut-être un mot sur vous
sur votre regard votre votre choix vos
actions à venir vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit le renouveau la continuité pour
ce qu'il est du modem 78 et d'ailleurs
je remercie l'ensemble des adhérents
électeurs de m'avoir apporté leur
confiance pour les trois prochaines
années j'en profite également pour sa
vie bruno myle yens et l'action qui
était la sienne mouvement départemental
pendant plus de sept ans il ya
évidemment une forme de continuité il
faut voir de là où partaient c'est à
dire que le modem départemental dans les
yvelines était un mouvement qui depuis
les différentes péripéties électorales
et notamment les dernières
présidentielles a eu un petit peu de mal
à redémarrer après les bons scores que
françois bayrou avait pu réaliser
notamment en 2007 et ayant 2012 mais qui
nous n'avez pas n'ont pas permis
si vous voulez d'avoir un ancrage réel
sur le territoire donc c'est vrai que
depuis 2015 les choses vont un petit peu
mieux pour nous on a réussi à trouver
nos marques on a réussi à élargir
agrandir la famille en rassemblant plus
largement
donc les priorités elles sont simples
aujourd'hui efforts de nos résultats
électoraux des dernières municipales
nous souhaitons poursuivre cet ancrage
territorial poursuivre ce maillage local
en travaillant davantage avec nos élus
locaux en travaillant davantage aussi
sur les sujets du territoire du
département du terrain évidemment nous
contribuerons à la politique nationale
ça c'est la vie d'un mouvement politique
mais je crois qu'il est aussi attendu de
nous et des adhérents à nounours en trio
sur l'essentiel et sur les sujets qui
l'intéressent les héninois et nos
compatriotes
vous avez évoqué françois bayrou et
vient aussi justement d'être reconduit à
la tête du modem national
c'est l'homme de la situation c'est
l'homme du modem comme en son temps et
on a rendu hommage
cette semaine au président valéry
giscard d'estaing comme l'udf leur saute
ne s'entendait pas sans valéry giscard
d'estaing le mouvement démocrate et un
françois bayrou sont évidemment de
choses liées
donc évidemment nous ont biffé on me
fait confiance à françois bayrou et
d'ailleurs les responsabilités qui
n'occupe aujourd'hui en tant que haut
commissaire au plan sont importantes
aussi pour la pour la france et pour
notre famille politique nous sommes
toujours sur le travail de fond sur la
prospective sur réfléchir à ce monde de
demain dont on entend parler aujourd'hui
à matin midi et soir mais qu'il faut
maintenant construire il faut se poser
les bonnes questions notamment en cette
période de crise et dans l'après crise
et c'est vrai que françois bayrou est
quelqu'un hommes politiques quand tout
est un homme d'état qui à cette vision
de l'avenir mais toujours les pieds
ancrés dans le terrain avec cette notion
de territoire cette notion aussi de
connaître et de savoir appréhender le
quotidien de nos concitoyens
compatriotes
ce qui est aussi une marque
de fabrique de croix le mouvement
démocrate françois bayrou qui est proche
du président un mâcon république en mars
pour autant quelquefois les les
alliances au niveau départemental ou
régional peuvent se faire aussi avec les
républicains cette fois ci est ce que
vous n'avez pas peur aussi que le modem
continue un petit peu de brouiller les
cartes n'ayant pas de positionnement
clair ou d'alliance clair avec une
formation une autre le positionnement
d'une augmenté mot crac aujourd'hui il
est clair c'est à dire que au niveau
national nous sommes soutien plein et
entier de l'action menée par le
président de la république et du
gouvernement nous avons d'ailleurs au
ministre au modem au gouvernement et je
laisse à vue pour leur action c'est un
papa un partenariat fort le mouvement
démocrate est un parti de gouvernement
nous avons un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale qui d'ailleurs ne cesse de
s'élargir en justement en permettant
d'élargir la majorité présidentielle
donc nous sommes partie prenante et
acteur de la majorité présidentielle et
de la politique de réforme qui est menée
après moi j'appelle surtout au niveau
local à ne pas mélanger les élections
c'est à dire qu'une élection
départementale d'une élection régionale
c'est avant tout une élection des
portages il des portes un mental il
élections régionales donc la façon dont
nous nous souhaitons aborder ces
scrutins mouvement démocrate et
notamment roman démocrate dnc d'abord en
parlant du faux il faut et nous allons
le faire ça c'est un des premiers
chantiers que j'engagerai avec les
militants et les adhérents qui sont un
membre de notre conseil départemental
évinois c'est un travail de fond réalisé
un projet construire un projet de local
à la fois pour les départementales et
pour les régionales et après se posera
la question de commandes nous portons
comment nous faisons un valoir nos idées
et nos convictions dans ces scrutins
mais attention l'élection présidentielle
c'est l'élection présidentielle
l'élection régionale élections
départementales que nous travaillons
avec nos partenaires de la majorité ne
doivent pas être des scrutins qu'ils
m'avaient confondus car ils n'ont
évidemment pas l'objet au niveau
départemental pour en finir avec ces la
question électorale est purement de la
politique politicienne au sens où il
faut mener aussi ses combats là sur les
départementales des candidats étiquetés
modem ce qui se présente ce n'est pas
exclue c'est possible rien n'est à
exclure
à ce jour aujourd'hui on a je parlais de
maillage
local tout à l'heure nous avons une
représentation nationale du modem qui
est clair nous avons aujourd'hui des
élus à la région l'échelon départemental
les chemins du conseil départemental et
par les choix pour lequel aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas de représentants nous
n'avons pas de représentation et donc
pour un parti de gouvernement comme le
modem aujourd'hui c'est évidemment pas
quelque chose qui a vocation à rester
ainsi à rester de la sorte nous avons je
lisais des idées à porter des projets
aussi pour notre territoire
donc là nous allons faire entendre notre
voix et si cela doit passer par des
candidatures modem soit avec nos
partenaires soient en toute indépendance
nous serons prêts à le faire mais encore
une fois surtout avec nous le report
votre nous annonce de ces élections
l'urgence en tout cas la priorité doit
avant tout être à la réalisation d'un
projet de territoire
il se posera ensuite la question
j'allais dire de la façon dont vous
présenterons à ces élections sur le
projet en lui-même même s'il est bien
évidemment on n'est pas encore en
campagne électorale non moins ya des
idées à défendre quels sont les sujets
les plus importants sur le territoire
que vous souhaitez mettre en avant du
modem justement incontestablement
aujourd'hui il y a deux sujets dans à
plusieurs y avoir de sujets qui émergent
c'est celui de la santé et celui de la
sécurité qui sont pas toujours
d'ailleurs la compétence même des
collectivités et des échelles de niveaux
de collectivités pour lesquelles il y à
des scrutins qui arrive mais on sait que
la santé dans cette période de crise
sanitaire est un sujet de préoccupation
de l'ensemble de nos quotidiens je
voyais encore aujourd'hui que un
français sur sept vit dans un désert
médical donc il va évidemment falloir
s'atteler à cette question activement la
sécurité et il ya des lois qui sont
actuellement débattu à l'assemblée
nationale est un sujet de préoccupation
évidemment je ne vous renvoie pas
tristes événements il ya tentatrice que
nous avons vécu dans le département mais
il ya aussi des sujets même si on entend
que l'on entend un petit peu moins
parler aujourd'hui dans le contexte de
crise qui sont la relance économique et
surtout la relance écologique la
transition écologique ce sont aussi deux
sujets sur lesquels nous voulons avancer
et on sera attentif parce qu'on sait
qu'il ya certains projets
notamment au niveau du département et
qui pourraient peut-être être revue
corrigée ou en tout cas où les choses
pourra peut-être un petit pain au four
ni pour répondre à ces impératifs
vous êtes également élu maire de
villepreux depuis cette année qu'elles
sont là aussi peut-être l'est dont les
inquiétudes que vous pouvez avoir
aujourd'hui en tant que élus de communes
élu local
alors j'ai plus qu'une inquiétude des
interrogations les interrogations sur
comment collectivités communes
aujourd'hui dans la période post crise
en nous allons réussir à trouver les
moyens les financements qui nous
permettront de garantir une qualité de
service à nos administrés
voilà nos concitoyens je reviens pas
évidemment sur la suppression de la
texte de la taxe d'habitation qui sera
compensée sané qui va commandes souper
quelques questions donc il y a encore
des sujets comme cela où on est un petit
peu interrogatif
et puis sur les grands sujets que
j'évoquais qui sont des sujets qui sont
à l'agenda des prochaines élections
là aussi on a besoin du soutien de
l'état
on n'attend pas tout de l'état et tous
ne passent pas par de la subvention par
de l'argent redistribué aux communes
loin de là mais on a besoin de se sentir
soutenu surtout dans la période qui
approchent et c'est vrai que parfois
même si l'ensemble des maires ensemble
ils causent sont toujours très
volontaire on trouve toujours finalement
des solutions on a parfois des lourdeurs
administratives et des compétences qui
ne sont pas en tout cas les nôtres donc
on ne peut pas intervenir sur certains
sujets je prends un petit exemple sur le
soutien la vie économique en cette
période compliquée pour nos commerçants
pour le restaurateur
il ya vraiment un paquet de choses
qu'une commune aujourd'hui ne peut pas
faire parce que ce n'est pas dans son
domaine de compétences pourquoi on
essaye de trouver d'autres solutions
mais là encore je pense que la loi en
tout cas sur certaines thématiques
pourrait être amené à évoluer en tout
cas ce sont ce sont des sous et qu'une
formule 1 avec l'ensemble des collègues
maires du département et de la région
donc ça veut dire que le modem soutient
le
mais néanmoins garde un oeil critique
malgré tout parce que vous parlez de la
taxe d'habitation c'est un choix du
gouvernement du président d'alors
attention ne vous méprenez pas mais des
propos c'est à dire que la taxe
d'habitation pour nos concitoyens pour
ce qu'il a payé cette suppression cette
suppression c'est évidemment une mesure
de justice fiscale ça c'est un fait
incontestable
moi je me posais la question en tant que
maire de villepreux c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas sans soulever quelques
questions et quelques interrogations
pour pour nous mêmes et pour les
communes pour répondre à votre question
ça a toujours été notre philosophie nous
sommes un partenaire loyal de la
majorité présidentielle et de et de 11
km seulement à la présidentielle donc un
partenaire loyal des différents partis
goût et mouvements politiques qui la
composent ce qui n'empêche pas d'être
exigeant d'être exigeants et d'être
parfois un aiguillon et même un lanceur
d alerte sur certains sujets où nous
identifions qu il peut y avoir des
blocages ou alors que d'autres choses
pourraient être proposées ou corriger ou
que la méthode n'est pas forcément la
bonne merci beaucoup jean baptiste à
monique maire de villepreux et donc
nouveau président du modem départemental
merci à vous merci à vous à suivre à
présent un long entretien accordé par le
président du sénat gérard larcher et
nous a reçu dans sa permanence à
rambouillet regarder gérard larcher
bonjour bonjour merci de nous recevoir
dans votre permanence de rambouillet je
rappelle que vous êtes le président les
républicains du sénat ce sénateur des
yvelines
on l'a appris la semaine dernière la
disparition du troisième président élu
de la vème république valéry giscard
d'estaing une image un souvenir que vous
gardez de cette homme petit souvenir
récent puisque je lui rendais visite
régulièrement et notre dernière
rencontre c'était en 2019
nous sommes téléphonés depuis une fois
elle portait sur la constitution le
projet de révision constitutionnelle qui
avait échoué d'emmanuel macron et
c'était aussi son attachement au
parlement je n'oublie pas que c'est à
valéry giscard d'estaing qu'on doit la
capacité de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel pour 60 députés ou 60
sénateurs ce qui est un droit formidable
notamment pour l'opposition
et puis c'est lui qui a mis en place les
questions au gouvernement
comme je les dis au sénat la semaine
dernière pas peut-être pour la plus
grande joie des ministres mais c'est en
fait quelqu'un qui a aussi renforcé le
parlement est tout le monde connaît
valéry giscard d'estaing l'européen
l'homme qui a fait évoluer notre société
sur la condition des femmes sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est un homme qui a été profondément
moderne
alors justement vous parlez du recours
devant la cour constitutionnelle ce
texte pourrait faire l'objet d'un
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel c'est la proposition de
loi de sécurité globale le texte a été
transmis au sénat le 24 novembre dernier
les sénateurs souhaitent à réécrire en
partie ce texte
on parle beaucoup de l'article 1 4 sur
la diffusion des images des forces de
l'ordre mais il ya aussi des
propositions sur les policiers
municipaux sur la formation dans les
métiers de sécurité quelle est votre
position par rapport à ce texte et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour
renforcer la sécurité des yvelinois
notamment c'est une proposition doit de
65 articles et traite aussi bien comme
vous l'avez dit de la police municipale
mais ce qu'on appelle le continuum de
sécurité parce que
on le voit bien face à la montée des
violences la réponse de la sécurité est
essentielle dans un état de droit pour
les yvelinois on le voit dans les
parfums de coopération entre les polices
municipales la police nationale et la
gendarmerie améliorer encore ses
relations le fonctionnement c'est tout
simplement l'intérêt des citoyens
ce texte prévoit aussi l'articulation
avec la sécurité privée
et puis là aussi d'autres aspects dans
ce texte qui peuvent interroger nous
deux ont assuré aussi la protection des
policiers des gendarmes et des sapeurs
pompiers
cette protection là elle nécessite
qu'ils ne puissent pas être fait
pression sur eux et je dois dire que en
15 ans les agressions vis-à-vis des
policiers augmenté de 80 % vis-à-vis des
sapeurs pompiers en 10 ans de plus de
200%
il ya eu un rapport au sénat en 2019 sur
ce sujet dochia de vraies interrogations
de vraies attentes
mais senna elle nous l'avons rappelé un
peu sèchement il n'est pas là pour
ajuster des textes il est là pour
examiner dans le cas du bicamérisme à
texte qu'il a nous vient de sembler
nationale que nous allons examiner en
commission d'abord des lois puis en
séance plénière et le texte qui sortira
des travaux du sénat
il fera l'objet du dialogue avec
l'assemblée nationale on s'est un peu
énervé vous savez au début de la semaine
dernière du côté
gouvernement et de l'assemblée nationale
ce qui m'a obligé mardi de la semaine
dernière a rappelé tout le monde tout
simplement
à la lecture de la constitution qui
porte le même numéro
partick 24 le parlement vote la loi
alors un tout autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la crise sanitaire et ses
conséquences économiques
les très petites et moyennes entreprises
ont été très impacté alors tout dépend
aussi du secteur d'activité quelle est
la situation dans le département des
yvelines notamment dans les centres
villes dans les zones d'activités
d'abord cette crise sanitaire m'amène à
penser aux malades aux familles en deuil
à l'engagement des soignants qu'il soit
l'hôpital en ville à ceux qui
contribuent au quotidien
l'accompagnement de nos aînés je crois
qu'on ne voit pas l'oublier mais
naturellement il y à aussi la dimension
de crise économique de crise sociale
je suis frappé dans cette permanence par
le nombre de jeunes à la recherche d'un
stage à la recherche d'un petit boulot à
la recherche d'une alternance
on a donc des vrais sujets à résoudre
qui sont des sujets du quotidien
on me disait ici pour celles qui
assurent l'accueil permanent qu'en trois
mois il nous a été demandé plus
l'intervention pour trouver ce stage
cette alternance qu'en une année c'est à
dire que c'est une vraie préoccupation
alors les entreprises dans le
département plus de 23000 déjà ont fait
appel au fonds d'indemnisation
il ya eu 35 mille demandes d'activité
partielle ma préoccupation va bien sûr à
toutes ces entreprises à l'emploi et
parfois aux conséquences de ces crises
qui conduira je le crains à vers les
pertes d'emplois mais il ya aussi
l'immédiateté que nous vivons en ces
temps de noël de coeur de ville de coeur
de village ou les commerces
dit non essentiel je ne sais pas ce que
très bien que ça veut dire ont été
fermés longuement dans une décision
qu'il aurait mieux fallu traiter
localement c'est ce que le sénat avait
dit à l'unanimité aujourd'hui il faut
les accompagner les soutenir et se dire
que la place de noël c'est d'abord au
coeur de votre ville au coeur de votre
village c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel me semble-t-il pour qu'on
fasse noël et que noël soit l'occasion
en quelque sorte d'apporter un peu de
baume dans les interrogations les
angoisses je note que beaucoup de
commerçants et d'artisans je le disais
mais il y à peu avec le préfet et nous
échangions gilles vraiment des temps
très très difficile pour certains
difficultés de l'immédiat vis-à-vis des
loyers des stocks énormes qui sont là
présents
il va falloir les accompagner au delà je
l'espère du processus de sortie
progressive du confinement
d'abord nous voterons la semaine
prochaine et sur le rapport de jean
louis devrais je crois que nous allons
dégager un accord pour que les élections
départementales et régionales se
tiennent au mois de juin qu'elle se
tienne dans un cadre qui devra être
adaptée campagne donc tu aurais de
campagne comptes de campagne parce que
la démocratie c'est tout ça c'est le
temps de la campagne électorale c'est
aussi le contrôle de cette campagne
notamment sur les moyens financiers
parce qu'une démocratie c'est quelque
chose qui est équilibré entre les
différents candidats et
mode j'allais dire d'expression du vote
la procuration confirmé ce qui avait été
fait d'une manière peut-être encore plus
large
au moment de l'élection municipale du
printemps question des salles nous
aurons des faits une élection ça crown
départementales et régionales
vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs que ce soit
ça se tiennent le même jour c'est qu'il
ya d'autres qui a déjà eu lieu et qu'il
faut le confirmer
taillon change pas les règles de jeu
tout le temps un je crois qu'en
démocratie c'est aussi des règles du jeu
claires connu l avance et dans lequel on
évolue pas aux regrets
j'allais dire des humeurs ou des calculs
politiques et il ya des endroits où
c'est difficile de faire tenir dans une
pièce comme celle ci parce qu'il ya des
mérites cette taille là le deux scrutins
donc réflexion autour des conditions
d'organisation des bureaux de vote et
puis bien sûr
faut-il ou non voter par correspondance
la semaine prochaine la commission des
lois du sénat rendra son rapport
son rapport et son avis sur toutes ces
questions soulevées par le scrutin et
notamment la question du vote par
correspondance avec j'allais dire deux
exigences il
il faut que ce soit votre sincère il
faut qu'ils soient fiables et il faut
techniquement à cause du deuxième tour
qu'il soit réalisable parce que
régionales ça veut dire le mardi soir en
cas de fusion de listes est ce qu'on est
capable d'éditer la profession de foi
c'est la nouvelle liste de l'adresser à
des lecteurs et électeurs etc temps de
voter voilà des sujets sincérité du
scrutin
mais aussi fiabilité de la méthode votre
regard sur les enjeux de ces deux
secrétaires au niveau région
ile-de-france et département des
yvelines du département des yvelines
je pense que chiche
et conforter la majorité départementale
elle ne peut pas être plus conforté
qu'elle n'ait puisque tous les cantons
j'allais dire sont représentés par des
conseillers départementaux qui
appartient avec une diversité politique
certaine mais à la majorité
départementale
ça doit être l'occasion aussi dans un
certain nombre de cas de renouvellement
de candidats il y à un certain nombre de
candidats qui ont dès qu'il se
représenterait pas et l'enjeu c'est la
place et le rôle du département et je
dois dire que dans ces temps où par
exemple vallée de seine les questions
économiques et sociales restent
extrêmement forte
vous voyez bien que l'industrie
automobile mais aussi d'autres activités
industrielles connaissent des
difficultés
en ces temps où il nous faut conforter
des politiques sociales
nous avons besoin d'un département
active présent naturellement l'élection
régionale est une élection est
essentielle beaucoup a été fait je dois
le dire sous la présidence de valéry
pécresse
je pense au quotidien même s'il reste
encore beaucoup à faire sur les
transports
je pense à la question environnementale
la question économique mais aussi on l'a
vu dans la crise sans les mères sans le
conseil départemental sans le conseil
régional
je suis pas bien certains je porte un
masque à cet instant qu'on ait pu sortir
de la première crise de la même manière
ils ont démontré au fond qu'ils étaient
au service des citoyens et du quotidien
en proximité car le sujet de la
proximité c'est un sujet essentiel dans
notre démocratie
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce 7,8
politique on se retrouve le mois
prochain à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]